I'm giving the perfect devil foods to
each straw hat so the other day I saw
that my friend Zach over at his channel
on IMD king tried to figure out the best
devil fruit for each straw hat that
doesn't already have one which sounded
like a ton of fun so I'm going to be
doing the exact same thing but I'm
convinced that I'll be able to find even
better fruits and at the end of these
all of the straw hats are just going to
be absolutely broken starting with Sanji
now Zach ended up giving Sanji white
beards guragura earthquake fruit which
would turn sanji's kicks into some of
the most devastating attacks in all of
One Piece no doubt a pretty good pick
definitely way better than what Oda the
author of One Piece actually proposed
for sanji's devil fruit himself send
your pink swim fruit which allows the
user to swim in the ground or walls
which yeah is pretty powerful but
doesn't fit sanji's fighting style of
kicking or his personality at all so
let's find him something that will
actually work with his power and enhance
it now sanji's broad range of abilities
actually rule out a ton of fruits in the
first place he can already fly and has
superhuman strength which does mean that
he doesn't really need any type of Zone
fruit that would give him any of these
abilities like for example kaido's
dragon fruit as you well know he also
has fire powers in my opinion ruling out
something like the magma or fire logia
fruits that would be sort of redundant
in this case and on top of all this his
genetically modified body gives him iron
hard skin and high defense value so
Sanji doesn't eat anything like the
barrier or Diamond fruit as well now I
think that one fruit that would
perfectly enhance sanji's Powers is
actually aokiji's ice fruits a logia
type devil fruit that would make Sanji
even more unpredictable and harder to
damage than even before also ice powers
would be the perfect balance to his fire
powers basically making him the Todoroki
of one piece and on top of that he can
use the cult to keep food on the
Thousand Sunny Fresh as well in my
opinion a lot more balanced than the
earthquake fruit that has pretty high
collateral damage to it but just as I
was about to write this down it hit me
there is one fruit that is even better
for Sanji and that's Robin's Hana
hananomi which would allow Sanji to kick
from wherever with countless legs make
clones of himself that double all of his
abilities and just imagine Sanji making
a giant leg just like Robin but using
his fire abilities and hockey with it
and without a question it would come in
even more handy for his cooking
abilities next up we don't have Gojo but
jimbei now Zach gave him the mythical
Buddha fruit wielded by Fleet Admiral
zengoku a pretty strong pick once again
let's see if we can improve on that one
now to pick the right fruit for him it's
important to remember that jimbei eating
a devil fruit would mean that he as a
Fishman can't swim anymore in other
words giving him a fruit would have to
be something so strong that it would
make up for that weakness and
coincidentally Oda just gave the perfect
answer to just this dilemma in the manga
where he just introduced the Jim base
cyborg clone seraphim that was created
by the government now clone jimbei has
eaten the swim swim fruit that Oda
originally suggested for Sanji which
didn't work at all with his abilities
but in jimbei's case it makes perfect
sense the swimsuit allows jimbei to use
his Fishman abilities on lands he can
swim and dive on land at incredible
speeds and even use his Fishman karate
which is able to manipulate any liquids
I would actually go so far as to say
that this is the only fruit that
actually would make sense for jimbei if
we want to respect his actual powers in
the story but let's move right on to
Frankie now Oda gave Frankie the arms
arms fruit that would enable him to turn
any part of his body into any weapon
very fitting for a cyborg who can
already turn parts of his body into
weapons and yes that would definitely be
useful for Frankie because he already
uses a lot of different tools but I
honestly don't think that a lack of
weapons to choose from is a problem for
him right now I mean if anything Frankie
is such a great engineer that he can
simply add those weapons himself after
all you already has integrated parts of
kizaru's laser Powers into his body on
top of tons of other weapons just in
random spaces now Zach gave Frankie the
gashagasha food which is a non-canon
fruit wielded by Douglas bullets a
former Raja pirate that allows the user
to dismantle anything and reassemble it
into whatever they can imagine which I
can't lie is perfect for Frankie and his
engineering Powers since he knows the
plans of the plutron for instance he
could even use this power to reassemble
the ancient weapon but for this video I
really want to try and stay within the
cannon so one interesting power for
Frankie could be bartolomeo's barrier
fruit that would give him incredible
defensive powers on top of his offensive
ones and make him even more tanky than
he already is but I do want to go more
into the offensive route of course for
example something like buggies Bara
baranomi would allow him to freely
manipulate and control his cyborg body
parts freely which would be pretty
incredible and this could even be
improved upon by giving him kids magnet
through foods that would give Frankie's
similar powers to bullets non-canon
fruit in this case he could just use the
metal in his surroundings to upgrade and
repair his body or freely assemble any
machine that he wishes but once again I
do think that I found one devil fruit
that is the absolute perfect match for
Frankie you might remember that
Frankie's bottleneck is actually his
Cola powers that can run out fairly
quickly and so Frankie would be truly
Unstoppable in my opinion with nl's Goro
goronomi this would give him infinite
energy to power truly gigantuous
machines and also give him incredible
offensive powers of course he could even
turn the Thousand Sunny into an
undestructible force of Nature and since
we just learned in the manga that
vegapan's technology is reverse
engineered from the ancient kingdoms
that also had unlimited energy in my
opinion this fruit would make Frankie
the most powerful character in the
entire world so make sure that you're
subscribed or I will send Thunder God
Frankie to get you that is a of course
means that the godogoronomi can't be the
fruit that we give to Nami by the way
that is exactly the fruit that both Zack
and also Oda Sensei would give to her
and yes it does seem like the perfect
fit for nami's current Powers at first
glance but not only do I think that this
powerful fruit is a way better fit for
Frankie as I just explained but
similarly to Sanji and his firepowers I
do think that it would be very redundant
for Nami to have electricity Powers I
mean having the godogoronomi would
basically mean that Nami would need
neither her climb attacks nor Zeus
anymore which both have given her
immense offensive Powers already so in
my opinion instead of upgrading
something she already has I would rather
find a devil fruit that actually
enhances her current abilities now
thinking a little bit outside the box
one overpowered fruit that I think would
make Nami incredibly powerful and work
well with her fighting style could be do
flamingos Ito etonomi which would allow
her to create these incredibly strong
strengths and so using her mirages to
confuse her opponents first and then
trapping them with her strings would be
super cool to see I think this ability
would allow her to make clones of
herself which would give her even more
defensive powers that she really badly
needs and she could fix things on board
of the ship and give first AIDS but in
the end I guess I also have to agree
that Nami really needs a fruit that goes
well with her weather theme now if
Luffy's father Dragon actually has
something like the storm storm fruit
that would of course be the ultimate
fruit for Nami but it's not confirmed in
the story yet at least so we can't use
it and something that might be an even
better fit anyways could be big mom's
Soul told fruit as you know Nami is
already using a homie to fight and if
she was able to turn anything from
lightning to fire to water into a living
thing that she can control or she could
manipulate the weather and much much
more on top of it and as some people
have argued that Nami could not use this
fruit for moral reasons but other than
big mom I personally think that Nami
would probably simply use her own soul
and maybe that of her crewmates to
create any new homies but luckily we
don't even have to debate this moral
dilemma because my personal favorite and
the in my opinion perfect fruit for Nami
would be kaido's dragon fruits I mean it
can naturally create clouds in just
moments which would turn the entire
Battlefield into her terrain to control
where she could just drain down powerful
lightning with Zeus she could create
wind for the sunny of course she could
fly and on top of everything else have
the most ridiculous offensive power
imaginable now Zach did give this fruit
to usop instead or to be more precise to
usop's slingshot which I do find
incredibly creative and would look
pretty epic but again we really want to
try here and work with the straw Hat's
natural abilities oda's pick for usop is
the pocket pocket fruit which would
basically give his body infinite Pockets
which he says is perfect for a sniper
like him who needs places to store his
ammunition which I just gotta be honest
is is pretty lame in my opinion the only
devil fruit that I want for usob is a
mythical human fruit model giant I mean
think about it usop throughout the story
has become friends with all the Giants
of elbaf Dory and froggy oymon Kashi
hydrogen Andres Rosa as you probably
know the Giants represent usop's perfect
image of a brave Warrior of the sea his
dream so really what by the way to
literally make his dream come true than
turning himself into an actual giant
isn't that right Gojo what's that oh
yeah this devil fruit does probably
really exist in one piece and it would
be so perfect for usop but since it's
not an official fruit quite yet let's
think of a more suitable alternative oh
yeah that's a good one Viola's girogiro
fruit would allow usop to Target enemies
far far away but then again Gojo I feel
like since he awakened his observation
haki Andres Rosa I don't really think
that he needs that anymore me personally
I think all right instead I personally
would give usop a devil fruit that was
just recently revealed in the manga that
of marine Admiral greenball the forest
logia devil fruit I mean we already know
that during the time skip Usopp has been
getting really familiar with different
types of plans and uses them exclusively
as his ammunition so having this ability
in my opinion much better than the
pocket fruit because this would give him
infinite ammunition he could create a
forest and switch positions throughout
it freely to Target his enemies from
hidden angles and as a logia user he
would be way less acceptable to damage
and as we know he could also really use
the powers to drain energy from his
enemies and heal himself something that
would be especially important for usof
who always is taking tons of damage in
every fight which now brings me to the
man that we've all been waiting for how
broken can we make Zorro Oda gave Zorro
kaido's fruit which again makes no sense
if we're being honest I mean yes this
fruit is incredibly overpowered and you
can basically give it to anyone and it
makes them strong just look at
momonosuke but how does turning into a
dragon complement Zorro's incredible
sword skills which is what makes him one
of the most powerful characters in the
story in the first place Zack on the
other hand decided to give Zorro
kizaru's Light low gear fruit a pic that
I totally respect because that would
actually have been my first idea for
Zorro as well I mean this fruit let
Zorro still use his sword skills and
even create light swords as we see with
kizeru himself plus it gives him an
incredible speed boost but I think we
can make zaro even more overpowered one
even better pick for Zorro just like for
Sanji would have been Robin's Hana
hananomi giving Zorro more sword arms to
use but it does work way better for
Sanji here I mean he can Sprout legs and
kick wherever he wants but Zoro can't
just duplicate his sword so just having
arms pop up in random spaces would be a
bit of a waste for him alternatively
Zoro could eat a Zone like the spider
devil fruit and we use that for more
arms just like this Marine guy here does
and use some poison attacks but that's
also not really like Zara fighting
philosophy I feel though then again you
could also kind of argue that the use of
any sort of devil fruit would kind of go
against Zorro's Bushido codes so for the
sake of this video let's say we hold a
knife to Luffy's throat and tell zaro to
eat a devil fruit or else which one is
the best well I personally would give
Zorro none other than Blackbeard's yummy
yummy Nomi the darkness fruits think
about it its ability to nullify devil
fruit Powers depends on Direct contact
with the opponent something that very
much Works in zoro's favor as a
swordsman he's able to drain opponents
of their fruit ability so they actually
have to face him straight on with their
own sword fighting skills as a result
this would make even the most powerful
devil fruit users completely powerless
against him just imagine Blackbeard with
Zorro's sword fighting skills and you
get the idea and on top of that Zara
could just store infinite things inside
his pocket Dimension basically working
as an infinite storage source for the
crew so let me know which one you would
have chosen for each straw hat but in
the the meantime make sure to check out
Zach's original video right here and
while you're at it let's get him over
100 000 subscribers as well